let me ask you this
do you guys pay attention to
the skip baylesses of the world the
first takes of the world the stephen a
smiths of the world they're part of it
they're part of it it annoys you but you
know i don't think we take it we don't
take it that
some guys do have moments where they
take it pretty personal though but it's
just annoying like you you wake up from
your pregame nap and you got a million
text messages about what skip bayless
said about you
before a game cause some of that stuff
if to me is like borderline like
take it personal type especially like
when we're talking about like you know
the skipping lebron dynamic or some of
the stuff stephen a smith has said about
certain people
i'm glad at times i'm glad they don't do
that to me
um
you know what i'm saying you're not sure
how you would take it i'm sure not yeah
i'm not sure how i would
but i'm big on
i'll take it five publicly yeah like i
can i can
media coach myself right you could be in
the press conference yes yeah say the
right thing ask me a question iggy the
the marshawn unless i'm just here so i
don't get fined like whatever
it's when i have to see you again
that's when things can get interesting
yeah like steven a is uh
you shooting around before the game he
come out there hey what's up man just
started talking to you it's like bro if
you ever went on national television
and created a whirlwind with my life
before a basketball game and i didn't
perform how i wanted in that basketball
game if you walked up to me before i
said hi i don't know what will happen
yeah just because i would react
you know what i'm saying like it would
be literally grown man reaction in the
same way you say when you play
basketball you react to go get the loose
ball yeah you don't think about that
like when you when you talk about
something like that it's like bro i did
everything right with my proof game my
pregame routine i was in a vibe we had a
great practice we doing all this stuff
and now
randomly you bringing this up and you
and skip argued about it for an hour and
now everything that everybody is talking
about is just negative stuff with my
name and i can't do anything now i can't
go on instagram if i wanted to look at
something that was posted by
my wife
i can't go on instagram now because as
soon as i open it everybody's talking
about what you and skip was talking
about you know what i'm saying so it's
like if i had to deal with that dynamic
every day
i probably would have an issue with it i
can imagine i can only imagine i i'm
glad i did and i had to you know i think
after a while everybody sort of realized
that hey bro let's just leave dude out
of it